in London and elsewhere whether it's Bex
fosters or Stella Artois one in three
beer brands worldwide could soon be
produced by the same company the murder
of sabmiller and a B and Bev would
likely trigger job losses according to
market analyst Spiros mulund Rockies he
believes the new giant will seek to
exploit its market power both companies
are thirsty for wider geographic
expansion and that is very important for
both of them the other of course is
enabled specifically is famous for that
is the cost-cutting initiatives that
they take and the opportunity to make a
bigger profit from the same operations
the two Brewers will complement each
other well on the global market a B and
Bev has a strong presence in south
america and europe and sabmiller has a
large market in Africa and Asia Betsey
Trotwood is a pub in the heart of London
peroni is one of the loggers sold
here.one of sob Miller's many brands the
customers have eclectic taste my line
logotypes i like stella san miguel usual
stuff like that i quite like beer to be
a local thing so it's also some
variation their indifference I like yeah
lots of different kinds this is like a
merger between ale and lager yeah that's
quite good whitstable the pub owner
isn't sure if the merger will have an
impact on his business he says many
customers avoid big name brands on the
streets in London everybody that the
fashion is the drink crews that are less
well-known more interesting something
that you maybe haven't tried before and
quite often beers that are proved by
very small operators there are a growing
number of craft beer producers in the
United States and Europe but will they
be able to compete with the major
breweries
big Brewers we will they will want at
the very least to continue their
trajectory of growth through acquisition
and that's what the historic have always
done and if all the big players are out
of the game they will have to start
looking as they have already done they
will start hubcaps and looking towards
small craft brewers microbreweries only
have a small share of the global market
but demand is expanding rapidly and
small Brewers are already considered a
threat to the beer giants in Britain and
the u.s.